in other news another legal weird
horrible Republican news
Christopher Hassan the Coast Guard
lieutenant who had a kill list of
journalists Democratic members of
Congress and other prominent Democrats
in this country is not going to be
charged with terrorism earlier this week
prosecutors came out they had used the
word terrorism repeatedly but when in
court he is not being charged with
terrorism in fact the charges against
him are really really pathetic when you
think about it drugs and weapons charges
is what they're getting him on drugs and
weapons charges the man had an obsession
with neo-nazis we know that from his
search histories he was actively
plotting to assassinate political
leaders we know that through his search
histories looking up where they hang out
what kind of security details they have
where they live he had the weapons to
carry this out he wanted to murder
people and you're bringing him up on
drugs and weapon charges he was
radicalized by right-wing propaganda if
he were I don't know say a Muslim we
would call this terrorism if we found
out that somebody and literally any
other country in the world was going to
do this we would call it terrorism but
when white males right-wing white males
in the United States do this we don't
call it terrorism we don't charge them
with terrorism but make no mistake about
it what this man did what he wanted to
do what he was planning on doing is 100%
the definition of terrorism he wanted to
go down in history he wanted to become a
martyr for the cause he wanted to kill
as many people in as little time as
possible so
everyone throughout history would
remember his name is one of the worst
murderers in the United States and he
wanted to take out the political enemies
of Donald Trump right-wing extremism is
a major threat to our national security
and those are not my words those are the
words of the FBI and the CIA they have
repeatedly been telling us that for
years the problem is not getting better
it is getting worse as this country does
become more polarized more divided more
things like this keep cropping up you
know the guy sending the bombs the
people from CNN as van covered in all
those Republican stickers we have to do
better as a country we're seeing these
people who are mentally unstable get
their hands on weaponry that they should
not be able to get their hands on you
know the red flags the warning signs
were all there in these cases yet we
failed as a country to stop them from at
least in some part getting to the
planning stages of their attack luckily
this Coast Guard you lieutenant was
caught before he was ever able to do
some of this stuff but it shouldn't have
even been able to get that far he should
not have had the means to even be able
to plan this or the weapons to attempt
to carry it out that's where the
failures in the system occurred and
those are the failures that we have to
correct